tu comprends que quoi que je fasse ça
revient à toi et maman je ne veux pas que
tu te blesses depuis les derniers jeux
quelque chose est différent c'est ouais qu'est-ce que
tu peux voir comment tu nous a sauvés sache que je
ne peux pas continuer à jouer pour les caméras  et
puis s'ignore dans la vraie vie
elle n'est pas celle qu'ils pensent qu'elle est elle
doit être éliminée je suis d'accord mais de la
bonne manière au bon moment nous devons y
aller avant qu'ils nous tuent ils nous tueront les
gens veulent se battre je'  Je reste ici
si je suis très dur dans les jeux,
mais c'était des jeux, voudriez-vous
être dans une vraie guerre, imaginez que des milliers
de personnes sont mortes, que vos proches sont partis,
que dois-je faire, c'est la 75e
année de la faim  Jeux les hommages
doivent être récoltés sur le pool existant de
vainqueurs
je dois dire au revoir
alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait je pense que ces jeux
vont être différents
Oh
ici pour travailler
il y a il capture Zinedine la fille
en feu
mais vous les gars pour tout oublier  vous
pensez que vous connaissez les jeux de l'année dernière
w  comme un jeu d'enfant cette année traiter avec
tous les tueurs expérimentés tout dernier conseil
restez en vie
rappelez-vous qui est le véritable ennemi